my name is yani tseng i was born in
Vienna posture is the European
Commissioner for each and policy I'm
co-responsible for the further
development of the living condition of
all the 500 million Europeans I'm
convincing that original policy creates
the face of Europe guarantees the whole
variety we have in Europe brings people
together connects them
there are a lot of different projects we
have financed and implemented we have
co-financed for instance a large
telescope installation at La Palma the
Canary Islands we have financed a
wastewater treatment plant in Romania
and constancia
we believe that cross-border cooperation
cooperation between member states and
regions as we do it in the Baltic Sea
strategy when the Deneb strategy is an
excellent example to further improve
regional policy
European solidarity fund is a right a
new instrument aiming to help regions
member states after natural disasters
this is something where we show where we
can demonstrate the solidarity within
the European family thank you spoke now
I'm really proud to see all these
realized objects and that so many people
have contributed to that